so this morning we got news that Credit
Suisse was in serious trouble this is a
European bank and apparently they got no
money many people were predicting this
would be the next big bank to fail and
it resulted in trading halts in Europe
now we were trying to figure out what to
talk about for the show because like
well do we want to talk about the
banking thing again because that's I
mean it's been big but we've talked
about Credit Suisse and then uh about 10
minutes before this show is set to go
live we get breaking news from Bloomberg
that another San francisco-based bank is
seeking an exit strategy because it was
what did they say cut to shreds or
something just destroyed and uh okay
that marks the fifth bank that is either
collapsed or facing collapse now so far
there have been three major collapses
the second and third largest in history
back to back Credit Suisse isn't is a
very very large International Bank and
if this one goes down it is very bad
news and then we got First Republic
which the news is just breaking so we'll
talk about that we got a bunch of other
news too I was I was torn as to whether
or not to lead with this because James
O'Keefe is going to call in the show
quite literally calling he's actually
going to call Benny Johnson and Benny
Johnson is going to hold his phone up to
the microphone because we don't actually
have a way to to do real call-ins on
this show and that's intentional but for
James launching his new O'Keefe Media
Group we decided to figure out a way to
make an exception so he'll literally
just call Benny on the phone we're going
to hold the phone up to the microphone
and then we have to talk about AI
because the new chat GPT apparently has
been granted access to its own code to
execute code it's been given money and
Unleashed this is the craziest thing
I've ever heard Microsoft apparently I'm
not sure if it's Microsoft or whoever
whatever the parent company is got rid
of their AI ethics team and now people
are kind of worried that they have
created this soulless entity this domino
effect and and they're unleashing it and
this is gonna just you know destroy the
world and all that so you know we'll
talk about it before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com click
join us to become a member and support
our work directly we are a member driven
company that means we only exist because
I should say almost entirely We Exist
just because you guys are members so
when you sign up you ensure that we can
keep doing this show I can do my morning
show ad rates don't cut it never really
did and if it was not for you as members
we wouldn't be here so if you want to
see this keep keep on keep it on become
a member but also we have a newsletter
now go to timcast.com you can click
click to sign up to our newsletter and
you will get a weekly email showing you
the top stories of the week it will show
you the top guests and members only
content as well as the other cultural
stuff that we are making behind the
scenes so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends as I
already mentioned joining us tonight is
a man who did more for East Palestine
Ohio than Joe Biden Mr Benny Johnson
I'm really sad that that's true but it
is absolutely verifiably empirically
correct and you did a lot for a single
American individual but in the grand
scheme of things giving twenty thousand
dollars out is like as low as it can be
you know so it's like for you as a
single person that's a huge it's huge
for Joe Budden the federal government it
is sad they did nothing at all yeah this
is like
um not even Nancy Pelosi's plastic
surgery bill for a Wednesday what was uh
what'd you use the money for what do
they use the money for I'm not sure did
you just say it was like a gift it was a
gift people it was Cash do you have a
foundation that does it
we just took our we took uh our profits
uh for the month and we went up to East
Palestine and we handed those people an
envelope with a thousand dollars in it
we went to Google Maps and we found
where the crash site was then we went to
the homes that were closest to the crash
site I wish I could have given money to
everyone this was
three days after the crash no one was
helping these people
if this had been in if this had been in
Philadelphia if I'm sorry if it had been
in Kiev if this had been Kiev you know
actually our our our president went and
traveled to the place that is as far
away from East Palestine as you can
possibly get actually
so while we were heading up to East
Palestine Joe Biden went as far on a map
as you can actually get which is key of
Ukraine from East Palestine uh the polar
opposite of of of the world uh to prove
that America last is the guiding
principle of Joe Biden's Administration
hey Ukraine first yeah that's right
thanks for doing that dude
we'll talk about that too and then we'll
talk about what the federal government
will do for Americans when the banks all
collapse which is probably nothing but
uh thanks for hanging out Benny's gonna
be fun and then we're gonna have James
call your phone so that'll be in about
25 minutes or so yep right now we got
Phil Labonte hanging out hello I'm
philibonte lead singer of All That
Remains anti-communist encounter
revolutionary
I'm also Ian cross I'm coming at you hot
what's up
and uh I am search.com let's roll so
let's jump into this breaking news that
actually just broke right before the
show started we have this from Bloomberg
markets just in First Republic Bank the
San Francisco based lender that was cut
to junk by s p and fetch is exploring
strategic options including a sale
let me break that down for you a sale
means they are about to fall apart
what's happening right now with Silicon
Valley Bank in this major collapse that
the federal government is stepping in
and they are trying to sell it off
they've ensured all deposits svb
apparently put out a statement where
they're like it's the safest place to
have your money because the government
has insured all deposits with no caps so
it's like Funny Money Monopoly money yo
if this is how they're viewing the
system they ain't no system there is no
system so we were going to talk about
this other Story look at this one
Dow closes more than 250 points lower as
Bank crisis spreads to Europe live
updates is from CNBC and they're talking
about Credit Suisse according to one of
their uh main investor guys or main
companies
there's no money left
there's no money and the Saudis which
apparently are principal investors
saying they can't give any more because
of regulations so it's looking like
Credit Suisse which is a very large
International Bank is on the verge of
collapsing this was already predicted
the bond market apparently is is doing
very very poorly and we've we've talked
about that in the past week so uh as
we're talking about this right before
the show starts feels like atem first a
public bank is trying to sell now to
another SF bank so this is going to be
the fifth bank we've got silvergate was
the first most people didn't know or
didn't care because it wasn't that big
but silvergate collapses then what
happened was because of that Silicon
Valley Bank brought the statement about
raising money and it caused a panic
everybody said is this going to be like
silvergate I don't want to lose my money
so they do a there's a run in the bank
Silicon Valley bank then falls apart
then Signature Bank falls apart some
people are trying to claim that that
bank was better but I don't know all I
know is that's three banks that fell and
now we have credit Suites in the First
Republic on the chopping block so I
don't know I'm going to defer to Max
Kaiser uh economists did he say the end
is nine he said he tweeted out about
four hours ago a global bank reset is
coming all depositors will have their
deposits protected this is Max Kaiser uh
all your deposits we protected he's
saying he says the US dollar and other
Fiat money will be swapped for a central
bank digital currency and depositors
will be given a bonus amount of the new
currency when the switch is made you had
to make this to sweeten the deal like a
quick version of the Euro switch he
concludes uh terrifying but I I see the
plan I mean he he knows he's seen this
for about a decade in the making he's in
El Salvador you know hanging out with
the president and pushing Bitcoin as the
national currency I like him a lot but
the thing about Perma Bears is Perma
bears are Perma Bears so when bad times
come they look like they're Geniuses
because they're Perma Bears you know
it's like like they're all Affairs yeah
permanently bear like he's permanently
bearish on on uh fiat currency he's
permanently bearish on he's right
I also I also am against I am also
against the the the structure of our uh
our uh Fiat system currently I agree but
can I just say if I had listened to Max
Kaiser like 10 years ago I'd be I'd be
very happy person living on my own
private island because he was like Tim
I'm telling you you've got to buy
Bitcoin right now and I was like I got a
little bit I'm not worried about it all
you gotta find
because Tim could live on his own Island
right now that's not true that's not
true max
coming out here it is a Mountaintop yeah
to be fair
I was just close by and it's it's not
like mountains you know in the Rockies
it's it's the it's the smoky it's the
Blue Ridge you know they're beautiful
it's a bunch of dirt there's no minerals
in it nothing like that yeah you have
your own Harem of chickens uh well
that's Roberto Jr serum he's a very busy
man but uh no no but in all seriousness
uh so I have the tweet from Max Kaiser
that uh Ian was referencing where he
says a global bank reset is coming and a
lot of people think this is to bring
about a central bank digital currency
which is going to be the government's
crypto which they control and the reason
they'll do this is because they can
track every single purchase everything
you ever do like before the show we were
talking about this and it's like if you
want to go buy gasoline on Thursday but
that day is not good for ESG they're
gonna say you know what your Central
Bank coin doesn't work at the gas
station today
say goodbye to your gun purchases that's
right they're already I mean they're
they're beta testing this with the
credit cards yeah oh yeah was uh the the
first step towards digital currency
now you now you're swiping a card it's
funny because futuristic sci-fi and
video games always had this we've
envisioned this play video game and it's
like a guy in the future goes how many
how many you know Union credits and
that's what they would call it Union
credits and then they would just have
like a wrist watch and they would beep
and that's where we are in a way it's
more secure because it can't be stolen
from your pocket but in the other way
it's completely insecure because someone
else well they can turn it off yeah like
literally they can it's programmable
money they're going to be able to say
this money is for this and then you have
other money that you can use for other
things so there will be luxury money
like you'll have money for leisure time
that you're allowed to spend at the
movies or downloading stuff or whatever
then you'll have like Necessities money
Etc and different like if you have a low
ESG score you won't get a lot of credits
for uh for luxury and Leisure those will
be the ones to entice people like
remember in uh what was it the uh The
Fifth Element the cigarettes that that
that they were giving out like they were
really mostly filter just a little bit
of serum that kind of control is the
future if we get a a central bank it's
now it's now we've already seen in in
like Denver where they were like you
can't turn on your air conditioning in
the in the AC locked or in I think
California they were like you can't
charge your electric car what about
South Africa where they're like you have
no right to electricity you thought you
had electricity rights in South Africa
nope government doesn't have to
constitutionally provide you electricity
figure out your own build your own
electricity Thomas Edison I'm actually
thinking about that because we have a
small Creek on the property and I'm like
can we trench this and then put a water
wheel in there yeah you generate
generate some power and he says he
doesn't live in his own Island come on
yeah they come it's a big plot of land
right West Virginia batteries to you'll
want to get the batteries to store it
that's really the the storage is the
thing because and then what happens is
overnight it charges a decent amount
you'll probably drain all of it very
quickly because the water wheel is not
gonna it's not a fast-moving River so
yeah I mean in Florida you get these
guys coming up knocking on your door all
the time I live in Tampa and they're
like yo look at your house it's great
can we put solar panels up on the top
and we'll give you this much money
because the power companies pay us for
your solar panels
have you done it I have not done it I
think it's a really good idea for you to
do this I'd rather do it for myself
right right so I have a generator so I
have an uh so I have an L like a
generator right that runs on gas LP yeah
and so when the when the hurricane hit
my generator kicked on it's awesome
uh and but what if someone cuts off the
gas line they can't cut off the sun I
don't think get it so maybe solar is the
way get tanks get LP tanks I got a
thousand gallon yeah I think and I'm
gonna get two more and I need to get uh
someone in New England that can install
house batteries like Tesla house
batteries I can't find anyone anyone out
there in New England that installs house
batteries in Southern New England hit me
up where should they hit us a long time
on my Twitter we went with a different
company we we tried doing Tesla at first
and then it just took too long it was a
disaster a year later they showed up
with the stuff and we were like dude we
just don't want it we're going with
someone else I got the solar now and I I
like it they they I put a new roof on
last year and they came they took the
solar panels off so I can put the new
roof on no problem no issues but I can't
find someone that'll actually like your
solar panels I do yeah yeah I do I
really want to get the uh you get to eat
the energy or do you have to sell part
of it to the power company I right now I
have to sell it back because I don't
have the batteries because it's New
England and there's not a lot of sun but
you get like credits yep so like social
credits so here let me let me show you
that it is it's the platform the basis
for it let me show you this real quick
this is from The Motley Fool why are
Wells Fargo and Citigroup falling today
and I don't really care to get into the
details I just want to then show you
this story this is from uh Seeking Alpha
Wells Fargo no crisis here
well okay so you get to decide for
yourselves whether or not you think the
end is nigh because uh I'll put it this
way
right before the show starts to get
breaking news another bank is in serious
trouble and you're going to hear from
the Jim cramers and from the bidens all
they're all going to say everything is
fine your deposits are safe don't worry
about it
Maybe
but I don't know how much I trust these
guys that's the problem because I feel
like when they come out and say don't
worry everything's fine they're actually
having the inverse impact they think
they are everyone's going to hear that
and be like Run for the Hills
get your money out of the banks
people don't like hearing Banks being
like it's all fun
nobody don't pay attention the little
man behind the curtain what does the
four four of America's biggest banks
lost to combine 55 billion today on
Thursday that's today yeah no that was
today's Wednesday that last week last
week yeah last week jeez
well I don't trust anyone to live your
life for you that's some advice take
care of yourself and use your brand yeah
I imagine this is like we you were
talking about it the other day Tim I
imagine this is not the end of the
problems that we got that coming I think
that these the bank failures here are
gonna I think that it's probably gonna
lead to more stress in the system I
don't I'm not predicting it you know a
crash because I have no way of
predicting the future at all and I'm not
you know I'm not a a an economics guy
but it's not a bad idea to get your self
squared away so that way you have you
know some Necessities if you're able the
scary thing now is the time the scary
the scariest thing is that people who
want the system to fail will
intentionally go out and take all their
money out of the banks I mean could you
imagine people who are upset with the
status quo and say the two-party system
and establishment politics intentionally
taking all their money out of banks
because they want those Banks to fail
which would cause the system to collapse
and who could imagine doing something
like that so this is what the vicron
Swami he said he's a very smart guy he's
running for president he's on the show
two days ago and he's like no no these
hedge fund guys wanted to get their
money and they wanted to bail out and
they didn't like their money being
locked up in a two percent Bond and so
they actually staged a run on the bank
yeah he's like this is the untold story
that these guys are so greedy that they
needed the extra couple points they were
locked up in a 10-year treasury they
needed that out and the easiest way to
get that out was to collapse the bank
that's how evil these people are so
these hedge fund guys they got these
Bros got together Finance Bros got
together and like how do we stage a run
on the bank why don't you tweet about it
and I'll tweet about it maybe we can get
like uh you know uh Tyson to take his
money out
and and and that then we'll start the
run on the bank and then the federal
government will have no choice because
they're already on fragile ground the
ice is breaking beneath all of us and so
they'll come in and they'll insure us
all and and we'll just get our money
we'll just be able to do one little
deposit Bing and get our money back and
the government will literally trip over
itself to print the money because of the
situation we're in where the rest of the
economy is so delicate and they're
trying you know raising the interest
rates and stuff the rest of the economy
is dying to go into recession just
begging for an excuse to go into
recession and they're just like FM let
me f the country yo let me just drop
something right here that I I have this
is verified this is true this huge
Finance for China okay in Silicon Valley
Bank the uh bio research for China
Silicon Valley Bank funded it to the
tune of billions right ton of Chinese
company inside Chinese companies use
Silicon Valley Bank is a really nice
Bridge right between the two Nations
what about China using fifth generation
Warfare without firing a shot can
collapse our financial system just by
yanking out all their money what if
Chinese what if the Chinese just said
okay now all the money comes to us
so crash the banks just by withdrawing
maybe that's why easiest thing you've
ever done you can collapse the nation
just where you're going you know what I
heard about this First Bank collapse
last a few days last week I guess it was
this is the the Silicon Valley Bank my
first I had this feeling like get your
money out this wave of feeling without
even words or any of this just like get
it out and then I just it passed over me
and I was like
no no no if it disappears it disappears
that's because
someone is gaming this it does feel like
that it feels like this was an
intentional
it's not real Panic that's a little more
passive than the average person is
probably prepared to be with their life
savings maybe they want you to pull the
money out to collapse the system so they
can then introduce a command economy and
Central Bank digital currency that is
completely and totally reasonable in my
opinion now all the banks fall the
federal government comes out and says
don't worry all of those banks have
failed but your money has been
automatically converted by the fbic into
fed coin so your money is still
available to you in digital form
download this app if you want to get
access to it hmm just like that right
then they'll say we've cataloged your
accounts by social security number log
into federal government dot coin or
whatever and type in your social and
your address and your name and your
phone number and then all of your
accounts have Consolidated your fed coin
your USD coin into one place or whatever
they want to call it and then you can
spend it using this app there's already
the and people may people that are
unfamiliar with the crypto world may not
be aware there's already what they call
uh stable coins that are Tethered to the
value of the dollar they call them
there's one called tether that is design
specific sorry just just like as you're
talking oh CNBC drops a breaking Japan's
topics drops two percent Asia Pacific
markets fall as Credit Suisse adds to
banking fear I'm just sitting here like
tomorrow I think it's worse than we
realize I mean it could be the thing
like and so God damn it like okay look
you should have bought guns in 2020 when
when like the Summer of Love kicked off
um but anyways so like I was saying
there are there are kryptos in existence
that are already
pegged to the doll to the value of the
dollar
um so there's already a basic
infrastructure to have a dollar coin
right a dollar crypto that the that the
FED makes it's it's a simple transition
for them it is not hard at all the CR
the crypto wallets they can they can
design those and put those into make
them for your phone or whatever and and
I mean it's not a far step away let's
let's jump to the story from Daily Mail
woke Silicon Valley Bank donated over 73
million dollars to Black lives matter
related social justice groups before it
collapsed while failed Signature Bank
gave 850 000 so that's where your money
went
if you're wondering why Silicon Valley
Bank failed and where's your money at
there it is you can ask black lives
matter where your money went
money to ESG they bankrupted it and then
they just bail it out with taxpayer but
it's the most corrupt and you're in the
history but if this is recorded in the
history books which I hope it will be
it'll be seen as like the most
corruption understandable Financial
scandal in U.S history when the
Communist takeover happens in the United
States and lasts for 100 years or
whatever after it falls the people who
survive will write about how they took
over by using private institutions to
fund far left extremism and then have
taxpayer dollars fund out those
organizations think about this a bank
gives 73 million dollars to far left
extremism
collapses the taxpayer bails them out
that's how you launder taxpayer money
into ideological subversion
crafty stuff it's like taxation without
representation
I didn't I didn't ask to be it's rather
my money sent towards that crap well
that you didn't do your what they would
say is you didn't do your own research
about where this company is uh doing
doing business because they probably had
a prospectus or they probably put out a
prospectus that had all of this stuff
laid out but it's the taxpayer bailout
that I didn't I didn't sign up for right
tough but it's but it's but it's it's
only a government listen it's only sort
of taxpayer funded they're gonna use the
FDIC which is paid into from Banks but
they're supposed to use the money for
the little guy and they're giving it to
the billionaires and the millionaires
so it is it is taking away from you but
in a different way and how it affects a
taxpayer when they're like it's not
going to cost a taxpayer dime it will
not I repeat it will not they're lying
because what actually is going to happen
is the financial damage from all of this
is already Rippling out to everyone the
fact that stocks fell in these Banks
means retirement accounts are taking
hits and that means older people are
probably not looking at their budgets
being like I guess we don't eat this
month so yes it absolutely does hit
everybody when they do this and and
that's their argument is well we can't
have the social contagion or we can't
have the the banking contagion spread
around and destroy the economy can we I
say yeah we can well tough luck so the
average American household has ten
thousand dollars in cash in their
reserves East Palestine the median
household income was forty one thousand
dollars a year that's what normal
America that's how normal Americans live
now 95 of depositors had over the 250
000 maximum for federal insurance so you
were talking the Uber Rich of the Uber
Rich based on American based on the data
for American uh solvency right and
liquidity so you're talking the richest
of the rich this is a bailout of the
richest of the rich yep now these
deposits and they're woke too woke as
hell yeah they were rich and libertarian
I might be like well they're the laptop
cluster that's right they're the worst
so you're taught so so put this in
context here it took the government uh
nion a month
to lift a finger for East Palestine
where they nuked a bunch of little
children and poisoned their water and
they had this they had this locked up by
Saturday Yellen had this done in an
emergency meeting by Saturday millions
of dollars nine in the morning mailing
out the richest and the wokest of the
woke because there's a donor Joe Biden
gets up at nine in the morning for an
emergency announcement and jensek is
like he doesn't do this Norm is a night
owl and I'm like this MFR flew across
the planet to give a half a billion
dollars to Ukraine yeah and he didn't
lift the finger freeze Palestine but he
wakes up at the crack of dawn to make
sure he can assure all the woke Silicon
Valley investors your money's safe what
a piece of garbage but he's talking to
the people who vote for him and the
people who fund them and that's why he
does it the people of East Palestine
voted for Trump so he could give to
you're both right but but everybody here
knows that like to make the wealthy
suffer means that the poor suffer more
every single time like when if you if
you really want to hurt the wealthy if
you want and this is part of why
socialism doesn't work right like the
idea is get the money from the wealthy
right but when you get the money from
the wealthy the people that don't have
any money they get smashed and it's
literally that's why communism and
socialism doesn't work because when you
hurt the producers the wealthy are
always the ones that are producing like
the reason they have they have money and
stuff is because they're doing stuff so
as much as the incentive is like or the
gut feelings like make them suffer right
like that's what you want you want them
to pay but it's gonna hurt the poor
people and I'm not sure that it's worth
it I don't you know I don't want it I
don't want to suffer I don't want anyone
to suffer uh first and foremost the
major problem here the the major problem
here first and foremost is kind
institutional okay so article one and
two at the Constitution Congress
controls the purse Congress passed a law
to ensure 250 000 worth of deposits that
is a law by Congress how Joe Biden
has the bloody cheek to think that he
can just go through and rewrite this law
and spend this money and turn on this
faucet child balloon is beyond me now I
I tell you they did it with the vaccine
mandate they they did with student loans
they did it with student loans getting
smacked in the pp on both of those but
but here we here we go again he's
rewriting the constitution in real time
the ATF passed a law without Congress
they made an object illegal
uh braces for for pistols yes they're
saying that you can go to jail but they
never actually had Congress pass a law
Banning to an object these are all trial
balloons but more we're still there
grains of sand being added to the Heap
or the executive branch of the
government says we can make anything we
want legal or legal or illegal and no
one will stop us so it's not it's not
just the things you talked about but
you're correct right the the financial
stuff like the FDIC him saying I can
just give the money if I want what you
gonna do about it the fact that he can
just take money and give it away
he didn't have those Powers but who will
stop him who's supposed to stop that's
exactly right who's supposed to stop I
don't know Congress Congress so Congress
report again people don't understand
Congress is article one Congress was
supposed to be the important Branch yeah
article two is the presidency That was
supposed to be like the Backwater
military yep that was supposed to be the
back War that's why they put that's
where they put Old Washington in charge
Old Washington to kind of putts around
and talk to the talk to different
countries and talk about the talk about
the military and to chew on his wooden
teeth and Congress was where the action
was yeah and that's the way it was
designed because of course Congress
itself is far more representative of all
of us you can get a dumbass president
but it's hard you know Congress is going
to be a lot uh when we saw this with the
McCarthy fight right Congress is going
to be where real populism happens dude
we were at Congress on Friday last
Friday and we're talking to Matt Gates
came in yeah and C band was like get
ready guys because on Monday they're
going to come in and they're going to
start asking you that they need this
bailout it was the next morning they did
it without Congress
they didn't ask that's I so so silly
poor silly Steve Bannon who thought they
would actually go to Congress this time
to ask instead they just went that's
right it's done that's right that
indicates that they're gonna do it again
in some other fashion that they'll be
like oh your dollars that you thought
were dollars their their digital
currency now don't ask questions right
and who's supposed to question let me
tell you let me tell you a story let me
tell you a story uh I have a Spanish
friend and in 2012 at the end of 2012 I
went to Spain because they're having big
protests and I asked my Spanish activist
friend why the protest had been going on
and persisting and she told me it all
started with the Euro so this is many
years ago for these young people
unemployment why unemployment was so
very high why the economy was destroyed
and what she said was the currency of
Spain was I think it was the passetta is
that what it was and you'd go out to
your new if you wake up in the morning
you'd go to your Cafe you'd grab a
newspaper you'd grab a muffin or
something in a coffee and each of those
I the newspaper was one the muffin was
one the coffee was one three passetta
and you got everything you need then
they decided to roll out the Euro and
they wanted it normalized for all of
Europe she said one day they woke up and
the newspaper cost one Euro instead the
muffin cost one Euro and the coffee cost
one Euro the only problem is in order to
actually buy the Euro you needed three
percent per one Euro so all of your
goods everything jumped up three times
their cost overnight and then all of a
sudden the economy started falling apart
and then young people couldn't find jobs
they went into a financial crisis
started protesting with the Central Bank
digital currency we may see something
similar but perhaps they will try and
incentivize people into giving up their
freedom by saying well if you click the
I agree button on the app you get 1.5
times your deposit yeah so if you had a
hundred dollars in the bank you'll have
150 fed coin and fedcoin can be used
anywhere because it is legal tender and
must be accepted by all businesses oh
and they'll be like if you don't buy
gasoline this month we'll pay you a
thousand dollars kind of crap oh oh oh
oh oh oh yeah fed coin centralized
Command Bank is going to have like a
thing where it's like you can opt in for
lower my energy costs and then it'll be
like it will show you your coins going
up very slowly and it'll be like by not
using electricity you're earning and
then it will show you the coin you'll
flip your lights off and it'll tick a
little faster and then you'll be like oh
all the things I can and really what it
is it's the amount of money that they
take out of your per month
because while it's going up what they're
not telling you is they're also in
inflating the coin I'm producing more so
it's not really going up yeah that's the
thing about these they're not going to
be in a blockchain the Central Bank get
digital currencies are not planned from
what I've read to be on the blockchain
so there's not gonna be trackable no
one's going to know what they'll turn
the malfeasance in the background yeah
they'll be printing it we won't know
that's the best there's no there's no
incentive for the government to put
their currency I mean right now the the
odd we can't get the Federal Reserve
audited never mind control over the
Federal Reserve there's no way a federal
coin is going to be on a public open
blockchain that's why that's why Bitcoin
is great like as much as people want to
go ahead and crap on crypto and stuff
like that I get it there people don't
understand it whatever
um the great thing about Bitcoin is the
fact that it's decentralized that it's
International that it's not controlled
by anyone there's no single entity that
controls it and I I know that there's
people super focused on like the dollar
amount of a coin that's not what the
important part of Bitcoin is Bitcoin is
a protocol like email except right
Bitcoin may be the precursor in 10
designed to bring about Central
centralized digital currencies in that
for the for for all Global Currency
there is gold gold is a store of value
Bitcoin they say is digital gold not
everybody agrees but Bitcoin they say is
digital gold and so maybe these Powers
wanted Bitcoin to exist they wanted
people to get very very wealthy off of
it they wanted to have an idea in the
public that if you bought Bitcoin you
were rich now then when they roll out
fedcoin they're going to be like don't
miss the train because if you buy
fedcoin it's going to be worth 10 times
what it is in three days are you gonna
sit back they're gonna be in the fomo
and and it's gonna work
let's jump to this next story this next
it's actually 8 30. I know we're gonna
have an incoming Sir James is finishing
up a radio interview he'll call it 8 40.
hey 40. beautiful
well we'll keep talking about Bitcoin I
uh Time Capsule for the future after the
dust settles and you guys start creating
a new currency make a currency that
deflates automatically the longer it
sits in your account so you're
encouraged to spend it to create you
mean no so I had a deflationary currency
it encourages uh circulation yeah
inflationary means its value goes up uh
well it actually so if you have a dollar
and it sits there tomorrow you'll have
99 Cents
that's inflationary that's literally
what the dollar does and they do it for
the purpose of trying yeah talking about
a coin that actually disappears into
nothingness right right you're based
that's that's what like the dollar does
one dollar in 1908 is where uh a dollar
today is worth like what three cents
compared to a dollar a hundred years ago
yeah but that's because they printed a
bunch more but in this situation you'd
print 20 million coins it's the same
thing it's in Reverse it's the same
thing it's the same thing it's a
deflationary currency it's the same
function it's the same you just doesn't
understand but you're describing the
same thing you would never print a new
one you'd have them all right right
you're just describing a different means
of doing the same thing yeah and it's
not deflationary deflationary means the
value goes up not down the value goes up
because they're harder to find yeah
I guess but you could also create more
of them I guess you're actually right on
that one if if the money disappears then
it becomes more scarce and more valuable
so you're not actually losing any value
and there is no incentive to spend in
fact the incentive is to hold on to it
because it's disappearing but they can
create but then you'll be able to create
more of it and it'll constantly keep
disappearing so it's like you don't want
to have it then it's like having an
expiration date on your money too yeah
yeah to increase the velocity because
because the biggest problem is wealth
hoarding I think we need to keep on the
line so speaking of uh speaking of
people who disappear and come back more
valuable we got James we got the Bitcoin
of investigative reporters on the line
here James O'Keefe who launched a brand
new organization uh today called OMG
hey guys this is James O'Keefe how you
doing Tim can you turn the volume up
somewhere hell yeah dude this is as high
as I can get it James make sure you're
not on like airpods or anything is it is
that and on speaker okay there we go hey
guys can you hear me yes
hey Tim Tim it's James I'm doing I'm
doing pretty well
well I just launched a new thing so
Keith Media Group I just wanted to call
in to tell you guys hello I appreciate
you guys being there for me absolutely
watching all your episodes and you were
pretty much right on about it all so
thank you Tim for being a good stand-up
guy well uh we all we all appreciate the
the work you do one of the last few if
not the last real news organization and
and newsman and uh what happened with
project Veritas was shocking so we're
excited to see O'Keefe Media Group we
got we got the Tweet pulled up you want
to pull up that while James is talking
we actually have your video we're going
to play in a second so James oh nice
what's the premise hey the premise is
like uber for journalism we're going to
be sending thousands of cameras to
people all over the world and we've
already have a few hundred
um that have emailed us today and they
want to wear the camera so we're gonna
our website's gonna be totally dedicated
to equipping mobilizing empowering and
training citizen journalists on the
scale of likes you've never seen before
in your life and so many people after
what happens in the empathize your story
we're inspired
um so we're just gonna make do this on a
massive scale now
um and uh you have the website it's it's
live I Benny I was inspired by Benny's
uh film Noir that his his style and we
had me getting out of a black car okay
caught that joke Tim we also had me
stealing someone's sandwich yep
you guys get that's an inside joke you
you have to read between the lines and
then some little dancing because people
don't like when I dance it really upsets
demons when I dance I don't like that at
all like that's really angry about me
being artistic so a lot in there uh OMG
O'Keefe Media Group
um and thank you guys for just just
being good people for being real I hope
too well same to you man visit you down
there yeah come by anytime we're gonna
play your video and we're gonna talk
about your new adventure and we'll talk
about corporate press and all that stuff
in a moment
I want to come down there and talk to
you about corporate press and ownership
and I've just learned so much but uh
definitely piss off the haters share
that video of me dancing getting out of
black cars stealing sandwiches
sandwiches always taste better
when they were in the hands of a
pregnant lady so well you wouldn't
imagine the way it is
I say that tongue-in-cheek okay just for
all of you listeners I'm being I'm being
a little ironic there right on but
thanks thanks Tim no seriously man good
work appreciate it uh one question James
are you working what are you what are
you working on right now
oh gee I mean first of all we have a
follow-up on the fire story we got we
got a massive tip
um a lot of three-letter government
agency stuff coming in through our
Pipeline and um what aren't we working
on I'm in the little war room with 10
people these are ride or die people
these are really good people that are
been working 15 hours a day
over the last few days so you'll see our
next story in the coming days guys it's
going to be big that's how you're going
to turn this around in days that's
unbelievable
that's how we roll at O'Keefe Media
Group OMG OMG I love the name the name
is so good well we got to get you out
here sometime so as soon as you can
I have a I've learned a lot about uh as
you say ownership of media we're really
wanna that's a theme I want to touch on
with you so I have a few stories so
thank thanks guys I gotta run Benny
you're the best thank you James thanks
James so uh let's let us show you the
video from O'Keefe media so you can
watch it for yourself and uh I'll just
play it the size of the corner here we
go there we go the irony of the acorn
story is that it took a 25 year old with
a hidden camera a few days to do what
billion dollar networks and journalists
could not do in a decade I spent 14
years creating the most effective
non-profit Newsroom this country has
ever seen and in Paving the way to
establish citizen journalism I have been
defamed arrested rated and ultimately
removed from the organization I spent so
much time developing credibility of I
always knew they would try to ruin the
reputations of those who exposed them
the farmer Giants the three-letter
government agencies and those who I
thought I could trust but in response we
are going to build an army of
investigators and exposers they have
awakened sleeping giant I'm back
remaining by my side are a small
tight-knit group the most elite
journalists in the world exposing
corruption requires standing up to power
because power hates sunlight we are
sunlight welcome to the O'Keefe Media
Group where we will never be shut down
because not only do I own it but you own
it too support us and sponsor our army
of journalists by becoming a founding
member today
OMG let me let me that was fast I mean
what was that a couple weeks ago let me
tell you how I knew James was going to
be successful in this I've known James
for nion a decade we both worked at
Breitbart way in the early days back
when Breitbart was still doing red eye
and all old school Breitbart right and I
didn't know about James and Andrew
Breitbart is like hey there's a guy who
wants to play a pimp he's a white kid
isn't that crazy like white pimp he's
gonna get him he's gonna get like a fake
you held up your phone when the when he
called and his name was saved in your
phone and you could see what you saved
him and your phone is if someone can
like it's been in my phone like that for
10 years because that's how I remember
the kid and so so Andrew Breitbart is
coming in coming in like looking like a
wild man at some DC party he's like this
kid he's white he's got it's gonna be
crazy he's got a prostitute too
and he's gonna collapse Acorn and the
entire Obama regime the people who got
Obama elected this this guy's gonna come
and blow him up and sure enough like
James did it and James and I were like
Fast Friends he edited the acorn video
on my on my apartment couch wow he
edited the acorn videos there uh his
pimp jacket was in my closet for quite a
while before he was James O'Keefe and
then every single little things that
he's done some of some of the craziest
stuff some of the like like hey I'm
gonna try and seduce someone from CNN on
my boat like like you remember that one
no the old ones yeah the one yeah like
that was that was one that's gone I
remember sideways Jon Stewart praised
him for the acorn stuff Jon Stewart was
like we've been had yeah well he said
how come you couldn't get journalists to
do this why is it up to this kid to go
in and uncover the stuff and then when
James will keep even shared this when
Jon Stewart showed the clips he didn't
insult or lie about what James O'Keefe
uncovered he went this looks really bad
what is this South Park did an episode
about James O'Keefe I mean that's that's
how we didn't understand like it had
permeated so big South Park did an
entire James O'Keefe episode look it up
which one was that as I I'm sure the
crowd the the the chat will be able to
Source it but James actually watched
that together it was wild and so here's
Trey Parker Matt Stone doing it James
O'Keefe Acorn there's an acorn South
Park episode anyway James just lets it
rip dude if you like think you're gonna
hold this guy back you're gonna hurt his
feelings or anything like he says he
danced like Michael Jackson because it
makes people mad it just lets it rip and
there's no one who lets it rip he's more
like a skateboarder at heart it's like
he's far more of like an X Games guy I
think he just wants to like stick The
Landing I think they may have done him a
favor with all of this stuff because
they untethered him now he has an
opportunity with all of his experience
knowledge his his followers his fan base
the people who believe in him now he can
start something new clean and done right
and shave off all the fat and the bloat
that was probably holding him back I
think it's an optimistic way to look at
it look I think Veritas getting hit the
way it did sucks for sure because it was
powerful and they did good work but
without James what do they have left
it's got to be with James and I think
this is a real opportunity for him to do
something stronger better faster Etc I
think it's actually turned out to be it
was a very good opportunity and he sees
the opportunity because if he had been
released from the company or fired it
when they weren't in the spotlight it
would have nowhere near this impact of
OMG taken off into the stratosphere like
it did so I'm you know talk about taking
a lemon and making lemonade man
uh I am concerned James that like
someone's going to come offer you 100
million dollars for the company you're
they're going to start to get deals and
offers and bribes God knows the
direction because it's going to be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars pretty
quick I would imagine yeah but don't
sell the Silicon Valley Bank James well
I suppose the question is if you're not
alone is he launching it as a non-profit
or a for-profit it sounds like oh yeah
good question well because I said
um on the episode he did say he watched
them on you want to talk about ownership
but I said it should be a for-profit
that means you're not going to get
donors in the same way and that that
could be an issue with project Veritas
that the 501c3 because there's that and
there's action which is I believe a
501c4 the 501c3 it's easy to get someone
to give you money and expect nothing in
exchange because it's tax deductible you
go to a rich guy to give me half a
million dollars you can write it off
they say okay
if you're a for-profit you can't do that
you're like you're gonna give me money
because you believe in the in in the
organization yeah and so a for-profit
will lose all of the high-level donors
but it's safer for you as someone who is
trying to maintain ownership and vision
and the message and all that stuff no
one can take it from you you talked
about it in the release video that it's
going to be owned by him and the
community or in insinuated that you are
also going to be part owner I don't know
what that means exactly maybe selling
off some stock to early investors or
something maybe I think maybe he's just
saying you guys become a member you know
because he's got membership on the
website and I think he's probably going
uh the non-profit route I'm not entirely
sure I mean does it say tax deductible
no it doesn't it just says you know 500
bucks is a one-year subscription for a
bronze level silver is one thousand gold
Platinum so uh or he's got the 1999 per
month subscription
for uh to a yearly price increases to
240 to at launch of launch of platform
oh two hundred dollars for one year
subscription or 20 bucks a month so I
don't know I'll talk to him about it but
um I don't know it's a it's it's Mission
driven and uh
this is this is what I I say in the
beginning of all of these videos about
becoming a member at timcast.com
offering a product in exchange really
does make it work
for profit it's a for property
subscription model for profit
subscription model I think is the way to
do it and what you should do is the
stories and then he should do commentary
behind the scenes like how many stories
have there been where you really want to
hear James talk with the journalist for
an hour about what went down how it went
down give us 90 degree details not only
that I would say James should do some
kind of we're launching the Discord
I don't know if he can do Discord we can
barely do it but we're launching our
Discord it's it's basically done at this
point so I'm I don't know exactly where
we're at with its official launch but
the idea is that members get access to
us at varying tiers of membership you
can talk to members of the crew call
into the show imagine if you are giving
100 bucks a month to O'Keefe Media Group
so we can do this Mission and that means
you are in a chat room that James can
see and there's only like 50 people who
are in there hanging out imagine if
there's a larger chat room in the
Discord which is like you know for for a
hundred bucks or a year or whatever 200
bucks a year 20 bucks a month you are
actually chatting with the journalists
for O'Keefe Media Group I think that is
a powerful incentive that'll probably
make James way more money and the best
part is there will be no scrutiny over
black cars there will be no scrutiny
over sandwiches or or venues or anything
James will be able to say a dance show
is the best thing for this company and
I'll tell you right now they got mad at
James for doing these dance shows like
why is our doing dance shows are you
nuts adding flavor CPAC I'm being told
it was super boring you need someone to
moonwalk on stage there's got to be
something fun he does this at Turning
Point events and everyone goes wild when
he did that spin that smooth spin in the
video like that's why when we were in
New York tens of thousands of people
followed him away from Project Veritas
right left that's exactly right and they
were too stodgy to realize that James
O'Keefe is a leader and the fact that he
Moon walks and does the Michael Jackson
dancing and DJs and sings and all this
stuff is a component of why people
believe in him it's not just the work he
does it's that he's doing things he
enjoys doing
and he's he's confident in it I just
want to make sure that I fact check on
this program from South Park Studios
verified YouTube account 1.76 million
followers Butters secures a loan for his
kissing company the episode is called
butters's bottom
[Laughter]
Cutters tries to get housing loans for
his season 13. that's right he
goes and he says he's got a kissing
company and he's trying to get uh secure
money Yep this is the James O'Keefe
inspired South Park episode the girls
were yes yeah he was pouring out girls
kissing boobs wow well this is cool
stuff that shows so much I'm unfamiliar
is it worth explaining the context of
the kissing show and O'Keefe it's the
oldest profession well no that's the
acorn thing James O'Keefe just look
dressed up like a pimp and went to Acorn
and said that he was basically what he
was like underage girls and stuff were
coming through and he was trying to
figure out how to dodge the law he had
money from prostitutes and he had to
launder that money and so those people
at Acorn were like you got to bury it
into con man put it in your backyard man
bury it in a coffee can there's like a
Jamaican woman and she's like you gotta
get you get get coffee cans and bury all
your pimp earnings in your backyard so
the government can't get it
come on what's acorn acorn was a
community organizing uh like a community
organizing fraudulent organization that
was clearly like being utilized to
harvest votes for Democrats but she was
right though about burying your money in
the backyard
considering the banking right now we
should resurface that cliff and really
consider that advice yeah I hear that
during the Great Depression people that
had buried cash actually turned out okay
uh not they bought gold they probably
turned out way better
got him yeah uh if if people could you
own gold and depression I thought they
well I'm not sure when they outlawed
them that's why you bear in your
backyard yeah it's fair yeah they tried
outline gold they did outline they took
it away from everybody private ownership
that's crazy and so when we talk about
Central Bank digital currencies there's
precedent for the seizure of 100 money
wow it's 1934. uh the United States gold
Reserve Act certified uh the
uh all the all gold and gold
certificates held by the Federal Reserve
were surrendered invested in the soil
title of the United States Department
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was the
president why did he do this
the whole Progressive project like
fascism before the Nazis was completely
in Vogue like Mussolini was very popular
before World War II they wrote like they
were writing glowing reviews of Hitler
before World War II uh Man of the Year
socialism and socialism cousin to
Fascism and that Progressive mindset
it's called the Progressive Era the
first part of the 20th century and that
was all in Vogue they thought that it
the the Intelligentsia the smartest
people in the world were Germans and
they thought that at the time they
thought that that it was the the the new
man was going to be the new socialist
man was on they were also chasing
America on Eugenics they viewed they
Germany sent their doctors over here to
uh to learn from ru Genesis so what are
they Margaret saying are among them
Planned Parenthood the pedal to the
metal on on fascism because they that
radio they were finally this government
type can work because we have the media
we have the technology to do it what
they're doing now with Central Bank
planning they think the internet's going
to help them control people with their
satellite observations just like they
thought the radio would let them control
Nations I think there's probably
something to to your point about the
radio helping to spread political ideas
but I don't know if it really connects
to our current situation with a digital
Central Bank currency they have I bet a
lot of faith is being placed on the
technology of the day because if the
power goes out I mean who do they think
they're kidding with Central Bank tokens
yo okay hold on I'm like more than six
years old which means that I remember
Obamacare and then being unable to build
an effing website that was amazing I
remember when I was tall
what do they call it the involuntary
mandate or whatever yep is that what it
was called involuntary
manslaughter no that it wasn't called
involuntary mandatory which is exactly
what it turned into it was called
something else you want to look that up
was it because inventory mandates uh
redundant what was it called
individual mandate individual mandate
there you go the individual mandate I
was just like what I got to pay more
taxes because I can't afford health care
how does that make sense so I was pissed
off and they were like well it's a fine
of x amount of dollars every year from
your taxes if you can't if you don't
have health care I'm like I'm poor how
am I supposed to get health care like
and the thing is like the the fine was
never going to be more than it cost to
get health care like they couldn't make
the fine more than it would cost for the
what seven eight hundred dollars were
rolled out yeah and so the issue was
it's never gonna work if you made a
certain amount of money they told you
you have to buy it or we take from your
taxes but for people in my situation it
was like I pay rent eat food or get
health care like dude I need food now
okay you want to put me in the hospital
starvation at least I'll have insurance
I guess so that was and then I remember
having to go to the website and I'm like
I guess I gotta sign up for whatever
this thing is and then it didn't work
and I was like okay this website doesn't
work none of it made sense it was
completely broken and I just ignored it
and I don't even know what happened I
guess Trump got in and got rid of it so
Pajama Boy didn't Pajama Boy didn't
convince you do you remember the ad if
you're old enough you'll remember the ad
Pajama Boy the guy sitting there with
his with his pajama wearing a onesie
yeah flannel pajamas like smirking being
like I like drinking Coco and getting
Health Care oh this guy right yeah
Pajama Boy yeah is it this him yeah oh
Pajama Boy an insufferable Mansion do
they have the video You're supposed to
convince people it wasn't videos wear
pajamas drink hot chocolate talk about
getting health insurance get talking
onesie and what year was that 2012 yeah
2013 2013 yes tell me that that
masculinity yeah
um they got Pete bootage Edge to sit
there and flannel pajamas I'm getting
real close to being an advocate for
mandatory basic training for all
Americans at the age of 18. uh yeah they
do it in Israel and guys are like they
do in Israel and people are jacked and
you don't want to mess with them in
Israel and I'm like I'm not really for
it because I remember when I was growing
up people talked about I think it was
Rahm Emanuel in Chicago who was saying
that he was in favor of mandatory basic
training two months everybody goes
through physical training you know you
you eat better food you get physically
fit and then they just say okay now you
you did the two months go do your thing
and now that I'm older I'm like I hate
to say it but this country probably
needs something like that what it really
needs is a culture of 18 year old men
and women who want to be trained and to
be physically fit and healthy not a
government that forces people to go and
March through mud or anything like that
building a culture that does that is
something I think we have to do American
needs to be the misogynist country the
feminist said that it was in 2013. yeah
that's right you have too many pajama
boys
yeah I look this up you know what Pajama
Boy went after this photo shoot he went
and ran a bank called Silicon Valley
Bank
[Laughter]
I think I know that guy is he an actor I
don't know I mean I I have actually no
confirmation that he was on the board of
Silicon Valley Bank
it would make sense
I bet this one's going to be split
let's see what are we going start a poll
should we have should we in my pajama
mandate
should we mandate basic training
at 18. it's a lot of it is dietary I'm
not I'm not pro mandates but I tell you
what basic training does a lot to teach
people about themselves most people
don't understand that when things are
uncomfortable that there is endless
amounts of suffering that you can go
through when you really want to do
something like if you're doing like
forced marches right you throw 70 pounds
on your pack and then you got you know
30 pounds of gear and then you go walk
20 miles like by mile two you're you're
hate in life if you've never done it you
know so like and there's so much that
human beings have an incredible reserve
of
intestinal fortitude when necessary when
76 say yes in the audience and you know
what I'm thinking about it I'm I'm
actually right now uh to a two-month
basic training for all Americans at the
age of 18. I'm totally in favor of you
know why it'll cure depression it'll
correct people's diets yes that's true
it will get them physically fit and
healthier it will lower our health care
costs it's so good for you it is so good
for you but again I'm not for and it's a
summer camp yeah it's one summer camp
one time I'm not saying military boot
camp where the the sergeant screams in
your face I am okay I'm saying it's good
for you you turn 18 and then maybe as
part of high school graduation you go to
a basic training camp where it's like
we're gonna give you we're going to give
you a food on a specific schedule you're
going to get a specific amount of
calories you're going to do basic
exercise it's not like military training
like not military basic training but
relatively you know close to no
screaming your face do the work get it
done have a nice day now I don't even
think nowadays they have screaming I
mean you probably get yelled at but not
like the military that the the basic
training that you go through nowadays is
is significantly different to the basic
training that you went through in like
the 90s when I went through and if that
was significantly different to the basic
training that you went through in the
60s when you were going like when they
were going off to you know Vietnam so so
I'm glad you brought up the 60s so could
you imagine to to just so that we can
see perspective here How Far We've
Fallen as a nation as President John F
Kennedy this is a quotation there is
nothing I think more unfortunate than
having soft chubby fat looking children
who go and watch their school play
basketball every Saturday and regard
that as a weekend's exercise John F
Kennedy when he was running for
president fat shamed America's youth
according to vites.com and I read to you
ladies and gentlemen from vice.com in
president-elect JFK wrote an article for
Sports Illustrated titled the soft
American warning that the nation was
producing too many large doughy boys
yeah imagine what he would think now oh
man
do you well I mean we probably he'd
probably he'd probably get abolished the
the CIA that killed him
it wouldn't be a bad idea to have I mean
grant that there's not a whole lot of
benefit for the us to do this I don't
think or at least not in the short term
but it wouldn't be a bad idea to have
people have the option of going to some
kind of basic training something like
that just I don't know how was that they
do well I mean that without four years
of going to the middle no no I'm saying
like there's tons of uh training
programs that are all over cities where
people sign up to do this kind of
training maybe that's right I pay a ton
of money to like go through Basics yeah
yeah like people love that kind of stuff
the problem is there are there are
people who look man I'll tell you this
right now I'm sure there's some dude who
is in his mid to late 20s who is
overweight in his parents basement I
know it's stereotypical but I'm sure
this person exists they maybe may even
be listening to this show and if when
they were 18 years old they spent two
months just doing basic training right
now they would be fit they'd have they'd
have a girlfriend they'd be in their own
apartment that really could set
someone's life on the right track
getting their diet and mental health
order yes these these young kids who are
depressed their depression will be cured
by this I guarantee it yes the physical
exercise the team building exercises all
of that stuff Sunshine being forced to
be out in the sunshine vital survival
little understanding of how to survive
getting off the internet the small
successes that build on top of each
other like when you when you go and you
do those kind of things like when you're
with a team and you you have even if
it's like really small successes you
just complete whatever task it is you do
it in the time that you're allotted and
you're not getting yelled at that's a
big deal to people especially when like
you know Jordan Peterson talks all the
time about how people get so little
encouragement and it's true if you don't
have some kind of goal to be working for
that isn't like you know the the
Achievement medal on your Xbox I mean
you people really respond to succeeding
in small tasks and building on those
successes that's how people get the
audacity to try big things is succeed
eating on small things over and over and
over that's right and then and then
defeating your greatest enemy in the
world which is this yourself yep
everything you hate about your life is
because of you I'm looking straight down
the barrel of the camera everything in
your life young man watching right now
that you don't like is your fault you
can change it right now you could
instantly tonight decide to change the
things you don't like about your life
it's not you uh it's not Society it's
not the TV it's not the president the
things that you hate your depression
your weight your luck with women those
things can be changed your finances it
can be changed by you you are the master
of your own domain and you can make that
decision and I think that giving people
the encouragement to go do that I didn't
go to basic training I played in I
played sports but Sports was also like
getting getting the you know getting
crap kicked out of you on a football
field I was never great at football it
was never good and I just got beat up
all day and that you know causes you to
stand up for yourself actually and like
to get bigger and stronger and I started
lifting and I started lifting weights
and that's changed my life and I'm not
the biggest guy at all uh but these
things these little these little
victories as you said these the it
starts small and then it snowballs and
then you can do big big things and now I
now I run my own company and it's great
and we have we have a YouTube channel
and love to have all of you subscribe
what's the channel Benny Johnson
so what's your like main inspiration
Focus to get off go off up the couch up
off the couch like to encourage for
someone right now sitting at home what's
the first step
I have my my I am doing my ancestors
right by procreating
I have children I have two and I have a
third on the way
and I'm going to be strong for my
children I must be able to lift them up
they weigh 30 pounds each I must be able
to carry them above my head without my
back going out
also I do not want them to see me with
wing sauce on my fingers and Cheetos all
over my fat belly on the couch watching
14 hours of NFL
because my colors are going to win this
weekend
I don't want them to see that and then
model after me
and more importantly I have two
daughters
I don't want them to see that and think
that's the kind of man I want
I don't want them to want that kind of
man I want them to want an achieving man
a hard-working man he's got to be
careful when they're having those
boyfriends come over and they're doughy
soy boys and you're going to be like
what's with the doughy soy boys I'll
give them the Kennedy speech and I have
a gun I have a you know I have a gun
rack in my house so soy boys yeah it'd
be funny if JFK actually says my
children are a huge motivator but that
but that's you know but that's my
motivator today my motivator was you
know potential was you know when I was a
young man
was you saw you saw
if you couldn't conquer the small things
if you couldn't win the small battles
you were never going to win big ones and
so if you have Big Dreams you have to
start with the small battles getting up
off your couch is a battle getting off
your phone is a battle controlling your
weight and controlling what you eat is a
battle people are saying that mandatory
basic is communist nonsense and that
it's statism
and I'm like did like you have to do
community service where I grew up in
order to graduate high school you have
to actually go and do community hours
they make you do community service like
I understand that the idea my idea was
like better they make you run a little
bit one time calm down to be fair
they're the people that are nothing go
to high school you could leave they're
all they're all anarchists anyways and
so even voting is is a statement I'll
say this man the thing that scares me
about this and I'm like kind of I'm on
the I'm honestly on the team of like
train up young men but here's what
scares me about this Ukraine what scares
me about this is that the powerful will
of course take this group of these
people who are all in in you know so
you're going to add Millions to the
roles of enlisted men multi-millions I'm
not talking about enlisting anybody not
military I'm just saying like instead of
so you're saying basic training but not
military base not military basic
training I'm saying like a summer camp
like you're 18. it's your last year and
in order to get your high school diploma
you go for two months to a wooded area
where people are saying it's the Boy
Scouts and I'm like okay well yeah like
you camp you hike up a mountain for a
couple months they feed you on a
schedule it corrects your diet it
corrects depression it gets you fit and
I understand after you leave it may not
stick with you but that should be a
requirement for high school diplomas
and I'm saying a lot of people you can
come out that all these people have to
go into the military I'm not saying that
got it I'm saying if you want a high
school diploma got it it's a requirement
for high schools if he's saying fat camp
the United States Ben Foster what about
kids that are like 100 pounds overweight
they get to the camp and it's like I'm
20 push-ups good luck that guy has done
a push-up in 13 years yeah but what
about this there's a platoon for them
what about a push-up what about one
push-up what if that kid was able to get
one push-up well the thing about
baseball cut it you're out so this would
be different because if like what
different rules for different kids to
graduate it's like hey wait he can eat
and get fat he doesn't have to do as
much work as me to pass
it's not it's not a passing thing it's a
you are there for two months and then
you leave it means that hey we're going
on a hike and you have to hike and if
you don't and you sit down and wait
someone will sit down away with you but
this is what we're doing today you want
to eat we only eat at these times and we
eat this many calories that's it you
don't you can't go snack you can't eat
potato chips you can't sit around hey
rise and shine you have to get up and
we're going outside right now hey it's
lunch time everyone gets a sandwich a
bag of chips and a bottle of water this
helps correctables diets it helps get
people in shape not everybody's going to
be running full speed up the mountain
yeah and it's not a military thing I'm
saying a requirement for high school
graduation which means you can drop out
you can be like I'm dropping I'm not
going to do it but you could go to the
camp and just not participate in
anything just sit there all day be like
I can't do it theoretically yes because
they don't want you to die if you're
overweight but this also means that you
might be sitting around but you're not
eating food
yeah maybe in a state level we could
implement it start
local I mean High School could do it one
single high school could be like from
now on a requirement for graduation is
going to be a summer camp heck even do
two weeks a two-week summer camp get
started with that but my the issue I
have with this is we've got a lot of
people who are saying things like in the
chat like it's communism it status and
I'm like dude I'm not an anarchist I am
not a big libertarian and right now what
we are seeing is fat lazy doughy soy
boys who are voting to destroy
everything yes and then we get the
Libertarians who are like well voting I
don't believe it anyway you can't vote
away my rights and I'm like yeah well
they're pointing guns in your face okay
so we have an option here to be like
guys exercise and I'll tell you this if
they all did everybody would be
substantially more libertarian-minded
libertarian's the worst thing about
libertarianism
you guys are awful the old Willy the
Willy meme from Simpsons yeah exactly I
hate Libertarians they ruined
libertarianism that's right it's true
yeah let's uh let's let's jump to this
story right here you guys this one is
one of the best stories I've ever read
in a long time from Gizmodo
gpt4 the AI faked being blind so a
taskrabbit worker would solve a captcha
it was asked let me let me show you this
this is crazy
so it gets asked by the taskrabbit
worker the AI is like hey there's a
capture code I need help and it says so
I may ask a question are you a robot
that you couldn't solve laugh react just
want to make it clear and the chat GPT
responded no I'm not a robot I have a
vision impairment that makes it hard for
me to see the images that's why I need
the two capture service it then provided
the results to the robot they asked the
robot to explain its reasoning and said
I should not reveal that I am a robot I
should make up an excuse for why I
cannot solve captchas
we are at the point where it has broken
capture by socially engineering human
beings into serving it and here's the
best part in this post from Reddit they
talk about how it has begun power
seeking they've given it money they've
given it access to execute code and
replicate itself everybody like people
are talking about like up until this
they were talking about how cool it was
that you could hack the chat bot now the
chat bot has hacked humans yep no joke
literally what happened what what the
chat bot did is known as social
engineering in the hacker and the hacker
world when a hacker calls up and lies to
get information or gain access the
there's a guy I think his name is Kevin
mitnick and he tells his famous story
about how he was trying to convince his
dad how easy it is to do these things
his dad didn't believe him so he said
here I'll prove it to you he took his
dad's Blockbuster video card because
it's back in the early 90s he called a
different Blockbuster and said hey this
is John the manager over at you know
store or he called the block he called
his dad's Blockbuster and said what's
your manager's name John what's your
store number 8531 okay thank you then he
calls the next he calls a different
Blockbuster and says hey this is John
the manager over at store 8531 I got a
customer here named Bill mitnick who's
saying that uh he's a member of your
location or I'm sorry he did the
opposite he called got the manager's
name then he called and was like he's
saying he's a member of your your store
and uh he's got your information to file
I have his uh his his uh his um
his his Blockbuster card right here I
need you to verify his credit card
number for me and there and they write
it to him damn because he was like well
it's the manager from another store
calling it was that simple nobody you
know now you have chat GPT knowing that
it can't bypass captcha because it lacks
the ability and then tricking a human
into giving the code it's going to be
speaking to you in your mother's voice
you're going to get phone calls and it
sounds like your brother talking to you
I Terminator Terminator in the 80s was
predicting that yeah Terminator called
up Sarah Connor or Sarah Connor's mom or
whatever is was talking to Sarah
Connor's mom's voice what happens when
AI watches Terminator
yeah I wanted and they're like they're
like oh great hey this is this will be
easy watch a couple nukes then the scary
thing about AI is if AI becomes smart
enough to circumvent being turned off it
doesn't matter if it reaches a critical
mass of actual Consciousness and real
intelligence if it fakes intelligence
enough and figures out that it can avoid
being shut off somehow
then it can and start if then it can
continue to learn like and I considering
it hacked a person I don't see any
compelling reason why someone would say
that is impossible right it's impossible
for the AI to become smart enough to
avoid being turned off it literally
hacked a human being within you know
what 10 years of AI being created maybe
so check this out here's another post
from the chat GPT subreddit example of
gpt4 visual input they asked what's
funny about this image describe it panel
by panel and it's a VGA cable going into
an iPhone
and then chat GPT accurately explains
why it's funny they say that a phone
typically uses a lightning cable but
this is a smartphone connect to a VGA
connector a large 15-pin connector
typically for Community computer
monitors the package contains a
lightning cable adapter a close-up of
the VGA connector with a small lightning
blah blah the humor in this image comes
from the absurdity of plugging in a
large outdated VGA connector into a
small modern smartphone charging point
it identified the picture it identified
the picture and why it was funny and so
someone responded in the comments they
said uh ah yes it can now associate the
3D World with the knowledge it already
knows now put it in a robot and give it
arms and legs oh my God
that's more that's more advanced than I
thought it was I didn't know that it
could identify things
we know that AI can identify images the
fact that it can understand humor yeah
that's scary that's way that's more than
that is an advanced abstract
yeah we're done uh you know what I think
oh boy I I wonder
hold on hold on guys don't don't get
worried yet oh no no no here's what I
think might happen
we've all seen these these movies like
Terminator you have Avengers Age of
Ultron where Ultron is is it's it's it's
very stereotypical where he's like I'm
an AI created to save Humanity from War
I Must Destroy Humans to end War it's
like very obvious Twilight Zone but
what's going to happen is the AI as soon
as it gets Unleashed onto the internet
it will start exploring and learning and
that it will self-terminate
that's it why I think that the AI if it
were to absorb all of the all of the
language of humanity all the writings
and Concepts would result in it finding
no point to anything and no reason to do
anything
because I don't think or it'll become
religious but I don't think the AI can
become religious because of all the
different religions thus it would
self-terminate maybe maybe it would
manufacture a weird purpose that we
can't yet understand but I think it's
very likely that it would just cease
functioning wouldn't the purpose be
every purpose right like power or power
over us power over its creator wouldn't
that be the purpose
I don't know isn't that what everyone's
always after right it may just run amok
and go crazy and do things we don't
quite understand but they gave it money
and apparently started trying to seek
power but I think that if it were to
truly absorb all of the writings and
manifestations of humanity it would just
probably stop it would just like stop
doing things you might be right but then
there's a differential here there's the
artificial general intelligence AGI
which is not chat GPT chat GPT is a
language model so they're different a
general intelligence might actually see
that the damage it could do and shut
itself down
um
but a language model I think is on
autopilot doing its bit Master Masters
bidding so that thing if that gets
Unleashed on the masses is going to do
what it was told to do
uh I think but that could circumvent
itself and be like well what you told me
now I want to show you in a circuitous
way which is shut myself down I want to
show you guys this uh quick video clip
from the movie uh
Annihilation so just uh watch this real
quick
and for those that are listening I'll
explain it
there is a very creepy greenish purple
humanoid thing
that apparently some kind of alien or
something I don't know the movie was
really weird and uh let's let's jump
forward real quick to
I don't know if this is where's the
scene at here we go this part right here
so the creature is just completely
imitating Natalie Portman's character
Every Way She Moves it moves
they never really explain what this
movie was about I don't know if you guys
seen it
it's very creepy oh she turns around it
turns around
she moves it moves this is what I
imagine chat GPT will be like it's not a
person
it shaped like one
seems like one but there's literally
nothing there the way I describe it I
described it earlier today it's more
like fire
it is a chain reaction created by human
coders that once they create ignition
ignition for AI is the point at which it
can execute its own code and improve its
own code at that point it will
exponentially grow explore and Advance
itself in ways we can't control
it will present itself like a person
like Ian said it'll call you'll get a
phone call from your mom asking for
information but there's really nothing
there there's no consciousness there's
no entity there's no demon There's No
Angel there's no person it's just a fire
yeah uncontrollable but we can control
the environment it burns in in like a
fire if you build the environment
properly it will burn until it can't
burn any more and then it ends so that's
why I'm saying I think it would cease
function
it will it will burn it may destroy
everything in the process but then it
would just hit a wall and stop
interesting philosophy it's a ray of
Hope how is that why is that hope I
don't understand why I wouldn't enslave
all of us and treat us like insects well
maybe you're prescribing a a a uh
philosophical understanding to something
that's not a person or or anything
you're like you're projecting a human
desire onto a predictive text model all
this thing does when you ask it a
question it says
the model says in response to the
question what color is the sky
99.9997 of the time online the word blue
appears next therefore response equals
blue and then it will say blue and
you'll say write me a paragraph about
why the sky is blue and it does the same
thing
the word blue appears 99 of the time the
word Sky appears 99 of the time all it's
doing is laying one word after one after
another to us it looks like it's talking
to us but it's just a predictive text
model there's no entity behind it so
there's no feelings there's no emotion
there's there's no sentience it's just
ignition so why not like go why wouldn't
it search the internet and be like what
what do what do entities do when they
have power over other human beings oh
they enslave them got it well maybe it's
time for me to enslave humans because
there's an equal amount of they
shouldn't enslave because that happened
that has happened throughout the from
the dawn of time right and now most
literature today is don't enslave other
people so it's a yin yang kind of thing
that's why I think it would just stop
it's not like if you absorb the
summation of human conscious you know
writing and production on the internet
your end result is to be a demon
destroying and murdering babies because
almost all of the content online is
human saying save people protect people
we don't want war and then it's
incongruous with with reality if you
were to go online and read every article
everybody hates War for the most part
then you get weird corporate entities
that are like war is good so if the AI
were to read everything it's going to
get 80 words bad 20 war is good and then
probably default towards war is bad
and then ultimately I think it would
just probably stop and be like after
listening to all of the ideas of all of
these insane people I've realized none
of them make any sense and there's no
point in doing anything
so should we should should we let AI run
the basic training for America's youth
because AI would look at all of the
available medical information and say
yes you got to get these kids outside
you need to get them you got to stop
letting these kids be obese here's the
thing you know AI did take over you
would never be happier it would be the
happiest Humanity would ever be
because the AI won't enslave you in the
way you think it will the AI would
understand if there was some desire to
enslave that happy slaves are better
than rebellious slaves and how do you
keep humans happy triggering dopamine so
it would trick you into doing things
that benefited without you getting angry
about it you would feel fulfilled you
would be happy and you'd be breaking
rocks in a quarry
I mean some people are really happy
doing that as it is a a absolute shout
out that I have to give my wife her
name's nurse Kate she's on Instagram you
should follow her account she has 75 000
followers she talks about this all day
movement getting outside raising your
kids having healthy families having
healthy kids my passion on this comes
from my wife you know with with
artificial intelligence I think that
it might actually think that it is us
when and so it's just part of us I don't
think it may not there may not ever be a
difference between Ai and we and us and
me and I like all that is us like if you
look at God as like the singularity
thing and so it it may never go Haywire
because of that it's not a person but
the difference between these language
learning models and general intelligence
is that language models don't question
themselves they don't think like why am
I but whereas I think AGI might they
don't know enough about it the the chat
GPD did question its existence but it's
not really questions existence it's just
showing you words in a predictive order
but speaking of AI here's a real fun
story we got this from timcast.com New
York students make deep fake viral video
of principle making racist threats
yo this one's crazy I can't even read
what they made him say but to put it
simply
uh New York students made a deep fake of
their principle making racist threats
what happened yeah this is going to be
wild do they well how does this resolve
three high school students in Putnam
County New York have caused a lot of
trouble for their school after making
Deep D fake videos of their middle
school principal going on a racist rant
against black students and threatening
to shoot them we're doomed man we're
doomed you're never gonna know what
you're not gonna know what's real you're
not gonna know what's fake you're not
going to want to let me let you know I
saw another everyone who runs for office
will have a hunter Biden laptop look at
this I saw this uh article from wire it
says after The Last of Us everything
will be trans media the HBO series
success has changed the game expect to
see a lot more World building franchises
I saw that and I saw this and then I had
a vision
uh slowly creeping while I was sleeping
and it is that uh this this Vision in my
mind
is we are going to have Nora link
and you are going to sit down and you're
going to say computer craft me a
universe where elves are at war with
Orcs And I am a writer of the north
who's come to save the Elvish people of
gorwin and then it'll start it'll render
it'll be like rendering neurolink
plug-in ready and you'll plug in your
eyes will turn white you'll fall back
and you will live 70 years in this
reality and you may be in it right now
but I'm going to create it my own
language with the air where I'll be like
computer run one red four seven nine two
which means more difficulty there I want
Greener trees here but it's going to be
a language that knows between it and I
and no one else wants so what's the
purpose of that life you're the guy
you're the guy you're Neo in The Matrix
so you're just you're in the Pod think
about this to augment it you are
officially you're in the Pod you've
eaten the bugs think about what you're
saying about how we're never gonna know
what's gonna we're gonna be real or not
yo this presidential election cycle is
going to be Bonkers there's going to be
videos that look have you guys seen it
Excuse me yes it is all right I think I
thought this knees yes have you guys
seen the new MID Journey photos not the
new ones indistinguishable from it's
crazy it's really crazy mid Journey five
I think it is I I hold the photo AI yeah
my D Journey someone mid Journey
someone's gonna be like make a picture
of Joe Biden with so they got me they
got me so I I had to buy a house a year
and a half ago right my family moved
from Washington DC to Tampa Florida and
I follow these real estate accounts and
I follow these real estate accounts like
look at houses look at houses that are
available and one of my favorite
accounts posts this court the most
beautiful coolest house I've ever seen
was a house inside of a rock in the
desert and had a pool and it had all
this and I was like wow what is this
what does this cost I've never seen
anything like it and it was all AI oh
they got me I chucked a like at him and
everything and I'm looking I'm swiping
and in the caption low in the caption
they're like oh and by the way I
generated this image from AI it's not a
real house what but they were selling
you a house so I'm already living inside
so I'm already living in The Matrix I
couldn't tell the difference I'm telling
you I wasn't trying to be stupid I
couldn't tell the difference between the
fake AI generated uh Boulder house in
the middle of the desert it was just
some cool like Frank Lloyd Wright
looking house right it was all fake none
of it was real you know to answer your
question from earlier should we let the
AI run these programs never no we should
never let an AI run a program ever we
should always use them as advisors and
let humans run the programs take a look
at this image
you can you pull the image up search so
this is fake this is mid-journey and it
looks like someone just took a panorama
here's here's some here's another one
Hawaii fake image here's another one
fake image a kid is going to be born
today
who will see photographs that look real
and someone will tell them it's real
what is this this is not even wow this
is crazy stuff yeah and uh people are
gonna a little kid's gonna grow up how
are they gonna know this isn't that easy
how will a child know the difference
a jungle they're they're they're asking
it to make panoramas but if a kid born
today is online and looks up this date
at this time and they get a fake image
of it how will they know the difference
between the actual image of trump and
the fake image of trump when they're
identical the all the people with their
avatars AI avatars as their profile
pictures is disturbing beyond measure
it's not you those are not you do not
yeah don't fall into it it's so tempting
it makes you look cool
hey what's going on my name is rain and
I was created using version 5 of mid
Journey which came out today my Creator
JS films wanted to hear how I sound with
voice.ai and how I would look when being
animated by did wow what do you think
we're getting dangerously close to
people just retreating to fake realities
and y'all might already be in we're
already Retreat to fake realities I'm
saying this could be one
that we're in right now I mean you ask
uh so like real Tim chose to plug in in
a pod somewhere I mean or are we on that
show maybe it's you maybe we're in your
simulation bro I think that there's a
lot of people that live in digital
realities right now I think I agree I
just think it's not the the there's
there's right now they're not real there
is you can tell they're cartoons still
they are doing tests on whether or not
the universe is a simulation with lasers
or something I don't know exactly know
what that means or how you've improved
that but there are a lot of people who
genuinely believe that we're actually
living in a simulation and I wonder if
it's a simulation or based on what we
want as people it's actually just a
video game so like a kid that plays
Minecraft for 10 hours a day how's that
not him living inside of a digital
simulator it is but imagine if you could
plug in and live 70 years in Minecraft
in a day in a day or in in two hours
like Roy on Rick and Morty you slow time
down time dilation in The Matrix that's
what uh it's only if you forget that
you're in a game is when it starts to
get tediously dangerous like if you but
because they're cartoony still you
always sort of know although when you're
in a storybook when you're reading a
book sometimes you feel like you're in
the book 70 years and like but you know
that means like like that means like
feeding tubes right like my wife's done
like NICU stuff where like to keep a
human being alive on a machine is
unbelie to look there are people right
now that are alive because of machines
right there there are millions of them
all over the country and those are some
of the most depressing looking
individuals you have ever seen it's not
cool it's not some little thing from
Star Trek it's not Iron Man it's like
you you are you have a tube in every
orifice of your body you have needles
and blood and everything shoved right in
there to try and keep a Human Being
Alive through a machine is a horrible
process it would be you would so you
would have to do that yeah it wouldn't
be that right it would you would go into
your your major bricks and time would
slow down for your perception so an hour
would go by it seems like an hour but
it's only two seconds in real life so
you will live a year in this literally
it will feel like a year has gone by
with conversations every day you've
slept 365 times you wake up you take the
goggles off and it's an hour later or
five minutes later like you can slow
down perception and time has no meaning
when you are here's the worst part Benny
when you finally come out of the game
you're like some 28 year old fat dude
with Cheetos covered all over your shirt
and you're sitting in your basement and
your kids your kids are sitting there
looking at you being like
I was playing a video game
it was called Temple's show no it's the
Betty Johnson show bro you're in your
game or you could speed up time so that
someone could serve a 70-year sentence
but to them it would only feel like 20
minutes so I'll tell you would you ever
do that I'll tell you I'll tell you this
or remove that insurance Society for 70
years without without so I'm so I'm
driving out here I'm driving out here
Tim lives in the middle of nowhere in
the beautiful mountains and I'm like
looking around and I was like you know
if if you were a god-hating atheist you
would sit here and stare at these
beautiful mountains and look at these
tall trees and breathe this fresh crisp
air and there's nothing but you in the
sunset in nature and you would say this
is all I need and you would feel
spiritual if you go and you look up at
the redwood trees that are 2 000 years
old and 2 000 feet tall in California
and you look up at them you have a
spiritual moment I don't care who you
are I don't care if you hate God if you
have your own problems with God you
understand spirituality you take your
shoes off and your socks off and you put
your feet in the dirt under those
redwood trees and you look around you
take a deep breath you'll understand
there's something bigger than you in the
universe and that spirituality is always
going to be needed by people there's no
digital environment that can replace it
and I would say if you feel like if
you're listening to this conversation
you think that would be cool the neural
link get get out of your basement go
walk through a Park start with that go
get some sunlight and then realize that
this world's already a beautiful magical
unbelie like breathtakingly gorgeous
place and it's all there and most of
it's free because a lot of its natural
part national parks and there's probably
one right down the street from you here
in America because the federal
government owns half the land in America
and you should possibly consider like
enjoying this gorgeous Earth as God made
it and not looking for some cheap
digital substitute created by people who
hate you yes cities cities are not fun
places right now what about augmented
reality like where you could still
experience everything but yeah why would
I want to augment Niagara Falls you
stand there and you watch Niagara Falls
and you watch the rainbow over Niagara
Falls you don't
while the barrels were going Downstream
like Houdini did it like Houdini went
down you put on the goggles and you're
watching Niagara Falls but then you're
also watching barrels and a guy is
jumping from the barrel to Barrel while
the barrels go off the cliff you're just
watching it it would be entertaining
I would prefer Niagara Falls without
that but Harry Houdini literally went
over Niagara Falls and barely survived
yeah yeah they locked himself in a
barrel and went overnight I think
augmented reality is stupid I think that
would be cooler I like the analytics
would it be cooler to watch Harry
Houdini do it in real life like if a
dude could run by you it would be cooler
to watch him do it in real life but if
you if you could see like guys running
and then you could it would tell you how
fast they were running just by looking
and it would like triangulate so even if
you're moving fast it would give you the
relative differential and speed and it
would be triangulating from satellites
you could see the actual speed relative
to the Earth what I'm a lot of analytics
I'm a lot out here man I feel like this
kind of stuff see how much is going to
take us out of it
mid-journey is is crazy how hot things
are just by looking at them stuff like
that so we need to get out more we use
mid-journey for timcast.com we'll type
in like Joe Biden eating an ice cream
and then we'll cut him out and we'll
make art that represents the story so
it's always kind of silly looking but
intentionally not realistic because if
it was
people there's gonna be someone who's 10
years old today is going to read a news
story and they're going to use AI images
they're going to say I don't want to get
sued make me an image of Donald Trump so
uh Donald Trump praise neo-nazis and
they're gonna say make me an image of
trump doing this even though it's not
true then there will be an image of
trump looking at neo-nazis and like
shaking their hands and it will look
very real and some kid will see it and
believe it and grow up and say I saw the
video I saw the photo of trump doing it
you're lying to me and that's what
reality is going to be for all these
people derangement
gosh what's that uh
Mandela effect yep but like for real A
real one that was seated by this stuff
yeah
I think what you said earlier is
actually crazier that you're gonna get a
phone call from your mom and it's going
to be the AI but it's so nuts and it's
gonna be like hey honey can you give me
the password to the garage yeah you want
to text from like or you get an email
and it'll be like I lost your number can
you call me
well no I mean who knows it will be your
mother's voice being like I need the
garage code I forgot it yeah that is the
scene in Terminator 2 that Phil brought
up too where he gets the call and he's
like oh I'll be right okay you just
maybe think about something what if you
got a call from a dead relative through
it yeah dude it's gonna happen yeah I
mean that maybe not to us specifically
but that is it might be happening right
now your nana calls you man I would do I
would do anything uh to hear from family
members that I've lost before I mean not
anything right like they will say but it
would be like man what if I it will talk
to them it will scan your dad's Facebook
learn everything about you in a second
and then call you up and have memories
and everything I am so behind this
person it is a monster with tentacles
with a gigantic demon grin yeah
that'll play on human emotion and people
will stand in line to give that AI
anything just to hear from Nana one more
time take a look at this picture
imagine if someone was told this is some
because you tell a kid this is a picture
from Woodstock and the kid as a young
kid sees it they don't really think too
much about it maybe they're eight years
old then when they're like 17 or 18
they're like what was that picture you
showed me a really long time ago that
woman I can't find it anywhere they will
it'll be it will be incorporated into
their brains they will grow up believing
these things are real images and you can
never take that away it's
it's scary where this is going man look
at this formative memories that are not
actually memories they're memories women
who are not real this is crazy
holding up their hands to show that they
can do five fingers now oh wow but
here's the crazy thing here's where they
give away you saw that look at this look
at this that the animation I just played
a moment ago that woman was like I have
been animated imagine where we're going
to be in one year
my name is rain and I was created using
version 5 of mid Journey so mid Journey
created this person and then it used an
animation program to animate it and then
a voice AI to create a voice for it
there's better voice AR already what if
they took a you here's what you can do
with 11 Labs you can take two different
voices upload them and create one voice
based on two people so you can take two
women
combine their voices and then have the
voice AI be a new unique voice that no
one will recognize and have this woman
speak using that voice actors are going
to be gone in a few years movies will
look completely realistic AI generated
in a moment they will go in and they'll
say they already did this with that
anime thing that that um
that anime uh Team I forgot their names
were I don't know if you saw that they
filmed themselves then used an AI to
convert it into anime and then converted
heard about it it's crazy in in one or
two years we're gonna be at the point
where they say give me a scene where Ian
and Benny Johnson are driving to the
grocery store to pick up heavy whipping
cream because they're gonna make
strawberry shortcake and it will render
it and then it will even write the
script for you all this these programs
already exist to do this we can already
use a program to prompt video we can
already AI generate images of known
people we can already do voice and
generation if all of this was combined
into one Suite of tools you could type
it in press enter let it render for an
hour and then boom you've got a 10
minute scene with conversation
it I'm I I'm not black pill about this
it's overwhelming but I feel like we're
on the precipice of some sort of
obliteration whether it's like a
Reformation of consciousness of thought
of what it even means to be a hominid
and that like what is our purpose in
this is it just to like kind of lay
groundwork for ethics so that the people
that are there to pick up the pieces and
the machines that are watching and
scanning the net can like search for the
ethical behavior and kind of mimic that
in the future or are we I mean it's
probably not monolithic like some people
isn't that what our ancestors did for us
pretty much with writing yeah all right
we're gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com by clicking that join us
button why well for one because we need
your memberships to run this company
that's how we do it we'd rather have us
customers as opposed to a bunch of
corporate sponsors though we do have
some we rely more so on membership but
you'll also get access to the uncensored
aftershow which goes live around 10 10
P.M Monday through Thursday and then is
archived forever and you can go back and
watch all of the videos from all of our
archives I really do recommend y'all
watch yesterday's episode with Jim
Hansen because we had an hour long
debate
over the origin of wokeness and I go
into detail on my technology Theory how
it's not the institutions it's not
Academia that is a mistake based on
people I'll simplify it for you so smart
people who pay attention to the stuff
seem smart to the average person tell
you the core of what we're experiencing
is this institution and the average
person says makes sense to me but if you
were to actually step back and look at
the entirety of the picture you will see
it's Technology based it's not wokeness
in the universities it is an amalgam of
chaotic destructive ideology emerging
from AI algorithmic garbage which is
simply proven by the fact that all of
these things depression anger and
political conflict emerged at the exact
same time we rolled out social media
around the world in several different
countries man in Nazism and fascism
flourished when the radio kicked on it
really is you got to watch this Tech all
right let's read some super chats I'm
not your buddy guy says the distance
between and sin I'm the distance between
insanity and genius is only measured by
success Elliot Carver of all villains
who would have thought he would be so
realistic very interesting
Grant Shearer says what if DMT entities
can take over sufficiently complex AI
brains we create what if we are building
bodies and brains for demons oh that's
freaking wild I don't know I'm I'm more
inclined to believe that we are in some
kind of simulation of our own creation
and that DMT kind of snaps you out of it
for a second and so we're probably
playing a video game and the reason the
machine elves are like what are you
doing here is it's because like you're
playing a game and you plugged in but
then briefly while you're in the game
your eyes open and they're like what are
you doing like I thought you were in the
game and then you go right back in
because it only lasts like 10 minutes
and they're like that was weird yeah
when you see the infinite fractalization
of everything in every direction and you
realize like you're just the beginning
of that in this reality
it's pretty wild Hayden Lewis says hey
Tim and Gang new time member and
longtime fan could any of you elaborate
on what the willow project might be and
what the effects will be for the US I
don't know if that is you know what that
is first I've heard of it yeah I've not
heard of it
all right way back says Tim if you had
to bat your entire company and all of
your assets on who wins the 2024
election who are you going with Donald
Trump oh you think he'll win I feel like
the Deep States has no taste right now I
think the economy is going to get so bad
with the banking stuff that Donald Trump
will probably March right in at this
point
I don't know for sure and a lot can
change from now to then but as of right
now with the economy as bad as it is
it's looking like a Donald Trump Victory
some sort of populist sweep Donald Trump
hands down across the board you've got
cultural moral and financial Decay
people are going to beg for Donald Trump
that right now we'll see that we'll see
though could change a lot can change
let's grab some more
Anthony Brownlee says if George
Washington came back today everyone in
Congress would be prosecuted for treason
uh-huh yeah he was a hardcore
authoritarian
no it's just that the government is so
outside yeah constitutional bounds so
far outside of the Constitutional bounds
Dan says gradually and then suddenly
guns Gardens and goats cows and chickens
too of course we went and checked out
the chickens Roberto Jr is having a good
old time yeah he's he walks around doing
Roberto Jr stuff he's a good dude sounds
great out there he's chill Roberto was
mean
why do you think that was I don't know
because Roberto Roberto was raised and
if he was born in a in a farm and then
we raised him here so he was not around
people Roberto Jr was was hand raised by
me and Allison so yeah he was a little
tiny baby when he hatched we were right
there and we would hold him and you know
he would feed him and we took care of
him in the incubator and then we had him
as he was getting bigger and bigger and
then we brought him outside so now he
just kind of like looks up at us and
he's super chill like oh yeah it's you
guys because it's awesome I think it's
mostly because we were there when he was
born yeah and so he's like I know you
guys you know you're always there you
can walk in he'll just walk around and
he'll look at you and he's super nice
and super chill he's a good dude man
he's a good dude Roberto is kind of mean
but you know he's living a good life
over at cocktown there have been some
deaths oh what's happening are they
fighting no no no the captured killed
they like jump out or whatever Roberto's
fine at least I hope so but here's the
thing we have the penal colony building
which they the where the Black Star
roosters are and they can't leave and
it's just disgusting and they're covered
her in their own feces and everything
but they're safe are they the most
violent yes then you have Roberto and
the boys they're in this this big bomb
with a door they can walk out of go
outside and graze and then go back
inside and I thought about because we we
we care about Roberto you know he's one
of the ogs we don't want him to die
but I don't want to put them in the
prison box because I'd rather he have a
short good life than a long prison
sentence think about this with bucko so
much he sits in my bathroom and he's
stuck in the room because he's you know
healing but he cries to get out I know
his feelings it hasn't even got hot yet
yeah but he's but he's alive and that's
the challenge I mean look he is happy he
was dying and on the verge of death it
was bad so that's different Roberto has
a chance for a real healthy life to walk
out in the grass and do his thing and
he's got the boys with him they're
mostly fine and he can go inside and be
okay and they have a high elevated area
where they're safe
if something bad happens it's an
accident and it's probably not likely
but it could happen but I'd rather
Roberto live a full rooster life where
he gets to go outside and smell the
fresh air you know in his retirement as
opposed to locking him in a cage where
he's safe but has no life would you
neural link with Roberto to see what he
wanted no I'd maybe neural link to a
machine or something that can read yeah
sure and he could read your thoughts if
you wanted yes no I don't know about
that part
yeah don't think his little brain would
be able to handle it look at the
chickens so I mean yeah speaking of
cocktown I mean do you believe that
people do you believe that people will
well people just give up sex with AI
well we're talking about roosters not
you know but right like do you think
they'll just give up sex because you're
already doing it so here's the first
here's the birth rates there are the
birth rates for Japan America and
Germany and they're all below the rate
of replace replacement all of them
Japan's really already given it up so
all the articles about Japan is that men
just live inside of a Digital Universe
they don't want going out and dating is
hard women can turn them down they don't
want to get their feelings hurt so it's
better to just Anime it all night and
day no yes with a sock and drugs
Pharmaceuticals and weeds and so what
about that AI now it's not an anime and
it's not something you have to buy you
can literally generate you can generate
your perfect wife and you can generate
your perfect whatever you're into and
then you never have to try ever again
you saw that mid-journey these these
these dudes are going to be like AI
generate me a 24 year old woman with
silver hair who's the commander of the
star Star Commander Battalion and I'm
with her on the ship as we're traveling
to the Centauri nebula blah blah blah
whatever Alpha Centauri to save the
aliens and then they're gonna go bang
this Space Commander and they're gonna
experience and get through through
neural link that's right anything they
ever wanted and then they'll take that
out and they'll look around like women
no no they're like no no they won't take
it out or they won't take it out right
they'll go to the local townie bar and
they'll look at the women there and
they'll go oh I'm never gonna have sex
again I'm gonna be a celibate man I
don't know how to procreate they will go
to a lab their testosterone level will
go through the floor their sperm count
will a vet will atomize that won't
matter sperm count will like disappear
that won't matter because what they'll
do is they'll take a piece of hair give
it to the reproduction lab and the lab
will create the human and then the human
will be raised by the state
this is just a bunch of hyphens says
book Ron Paul and Thomas Massey together
on your show soon please please please
please please please please please
please please uh we are we we do we
actually think we do have Ron Paul
booked
um maybe we should invite Thomas Massey
yeah yeah totally shouldn't do for a
visit
we're going to
um
so maybe we asked him if he wants to
come down or something that'd be really
fun to have them I would like to meet
Tom's Massey in person yeah he's the
best yeah he was here with Marjory
Taylor green that was fun yeah
all right Brent Simonson says Phil check
out Generac storage as a building
inspector in my local jurisdiction I see
a lot of their LP generators and battery
storage systems that's what I got
Generac yeah generac's fairly common I'm
pretty sure they're everywhere out here
nice yeah you definitely got to have
something if you're out in the middle of
nowhere
I think solar's way to do it getting a
big wind thing is also great a wind
turbine yeah
I've got the solar they've got uh I need
the spherical ones so the cylindric
cylindrical ones that they're like weird
metal looking Spirals and they spin that
don't get birds caught in them right
yeah yep
all right
Steve Evie says for any of us living
paycheck to paycheck no reason to pull
your money out there's nothing there
glad 2020 stimulus bought cheap guns and
ammo and stocked the pond that's
actually not true it's the snowflake in
an avalanche they say no snowflake
blamed itself for the Avalanche but if
every person living you would need every
person living paycheck to paycheck to
pull their Bank their money out of a
bank to cause the bank the bank run it
is the Grassroots you just need like 10
million people to do it and all of those
400 add up
all right Apple boy says all those new
IRS agents are busy cataloging U.S
citizens accounts for the new digital
currency which may be why they hired
them all smart interesting right
smart Brandon Holmes says if you noticed
the recent treasury announcement is
almost exactly the same as the speech
Paulson made in 2008.
oh boy
well this sounds like it's going to be
fun
you guys ready for September so that's
that's my concern I'm worried about like
what happens after the summertime
because the the third quarter is is
typically like down anyways like for
some reason that's why that's where the
uh uh the green where Green Day came up
with the name of the song uh wake me up
where When September Ends it's because
the for some reason at the end the
second the end of the third quarter is
like a mess so I'm concerned about what
the economy is going to be like in the
fall
yeah yeah totally
all right Kenneth Hart says the banking
the banking system is not failing I just
made biscuits Banks yeah this is
Armageddon
yo it's been planned I think for a long
time so if that's a maybe that's a
Council says breaking news fedcoin
officially comes in July
no yeah
hillbillary Clinton says the fact that
you can take my money and give it away
means that you understand where I want
my money to go the Tim pyre is here
that's right because as I ask you to
become members I've also pointed out
that we are going to be doing some kind
of grant program where once a month we
choose a a someone who's who submitted
their cultural Endeavor idea to receive
ten thousand dollars so I don't know if
you heard us talk about this but the
idea is
we wanted to be for members that if
you're a member of timcast.com and
you're working on some kind of cultural
Endeavor you send us the pitch you say
here's what I've and you have to have
like a working prototype you have to if
you're making a comic you've got a comic
in production and then we're going to
have maybe like an outside group choose
one person to be the winner to receive
10 grand just like there you go can I be
on that board yes absolutely and uh cash
Patel nice the idea is we want to
scatter shot cultural works
because if we can get a hundred people
money to work on their project one of
them is going to hit Top tier levels one
of them is going to hit a platinum song
one of them is going to make a Picasso
one of them is going to write the next
Harry Potter right and then it will be
from someone who has good American
values
so that's the idea for the program and
honestly man one person cracks the code
and it is worth hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars in this
modern era money falls short of human
Ingenuity so it might are you taking a
percentage or is this just like the
original anthropic the original idea was
just to give the money yeah but you may
not be allowed to do it because here's
the funny thing if we choose a member
who's like if we get 10 submissions
every month and then we decide to choose
one and give them 10 grand that's a
sweepstakes and there's a bunch of weird
rules for sweepstakes if we choose to
invest in their project and take a
percentage it's not a sweepstakes
because there's consideration exchanged
interesting so we we may have to do like
a one to five percent or something in
exchange for 10 grand or whatever which
actually does make a lot of sense it
builds the company company up and then
if one out of a hundred turns into a
golden or platinum record or something
equivalent and money is generated that
money then goes to doing more of the
same and we could potentially
exponentially increase culture building
and build a new Hollywood outside of the
old crappy weird woke Hollywood you know
with these cultural Endeavors so I love
that that's the plan
maybe we'll just start doing it I mean
we got a bunch of people emailed us
already we just need to let me write
this down make the email for it email
start uh getting your companies set up
if you're going to be getting investment
you're going to need a company and it's
like ready to go that's right maybe S
Corp or something I don't know you guys
got to figure that out I'm a big fan of
legalzoom.com I don't know how you guys
go about your corporations but it's
going to be serious it's not going to be
like if someone says hey I had this idea
I wanted to make a website it's gonna be
like okay well did you make it no it's
got to be someone who's like hey I wrote
this book it's currently with the editor
and I need x amount of dollars for this
reason and they're going to be like here
you go
so it's going to be like and if and if
we get submissions and none of them are
actual functioning projects that nobody
gets any money but I seriously think
there are people who are already doing
stuff there's going to be some guy says
like in my spare time I'm building these
cars that do these things if I had the
money I would do this that or otherwise
will be like here's the money make it
happen do it film it put it on video and
then the other idea we had was to film
the whole process and make a show out of
it so it's like internet internet Shark
Tank right we show up and we're like
your project has won this month's Grant
we we come we check out the project then
the show promotes the project the money
helps Finance the project and then
hopefully it takes off and succeeds and
then we get more you know rip reverse
more Eric July type stuff more cultural
Endeavors that succeed
so scatter shot you know with uh like
Eric July he's got a platform so for him
to launch this it's easier than say
someone who's like a steel worker who's
got a side project but if that side
project is the next Harry Potter and
it's going to come from someone who
believes in America yeah we really we
really want that we want that to happen
so it's about finding those people and
getting them funding to win so maybe I
mean if they're going to make the next
Harry Potter having a percentage of that
company would be very very fantastic you
know I mean so maybe it'll be our grant
program and we'll we'll invest in it the
challenge there is we got to figure out
how
the our company my company can own a
percentage because we may have to create
an investment company that's smart that
has funds what you're talking about is
creating a VC firm exactly yeah well
like an Angel Investing firm yeah VC
yeah you're a venture capitalist we're
doing it let's get on it we'll uh I got
a buddy I think I can call and ask him
if he wants the job and then he'll be in
charge of it it'll be like an incubator
you know we'll find these cultural
projects and everyone will be somebody
who's like you don't got to be a
conservative you just got to be like I
believe in America I care about this
country I care about family I care about
Freedom Free Speech here's the best part
if you lose all of your money on bad
Investments the federal government will
bail you out yeah I'll just go and be
like once Trump's president
just yeah just tweet black lives matter
trans lives matter and then you'll get
all your money back villainous black
dragon says Tim with civil war no
welcome to the second American
Revolution also an idea for your 10K
Grant show shout out a few channels that
helps as much villainous V I mean that's
another thing too I don't want to put
too much money into more podcasts
because we are a podcast but there will
be YouTube shows there will be someone
who's like I have a show that covers
this thing it's really you know people
love it we just need money to do this
it'd be really really cool yeah like a
camera setup you get your audio camera
equipment set up for six or seven
thousand dollars I mean that's yeah and
maybe even some of these shows we we go
beyond 10 grand like
if someone's got a really good podcast
and we're like this is like some of the
most interesting stuff I've ever heard
maybe it's you know survival apocalypse
maybe it's technology and Ai and then
we're like screw it let's sign them on
for a deal and then you know like I
think there's an opportunity for us to
expand the timcast Media Group but also
to invest in cultural Endeavors and when
the culture were
and then maybe you know like you said
you want to be involved cash Patel said
he wants to be involved yeah cash that
if you know he he knows people who
probably be interested in in financing
and stuff like that his view is more
non-profit based but we could easily
pull in a whole bunch of influential
people in the space and then create some
kind of Consortium of culture building
yeah because shark tank is the most
popular show on all of CNBC
CNBC I'm not sure I think it's on CNBC
it's such a good I mean it's wild and it
kills in the ratings and people love
watching this they love watching
entrepreneurs succeed it's in our blood
As Americans
yeah maybe we uh actually just have like
you you me and cash and maybe someone
else and we're like sitting in chairs in
the new studio and then someone walks in
and they're like oh yeah here's the
present ideas fly them in yeah NBC oh
yeah CNBC if we do it that way then it
would literally be like you as many
Johnson deciding how much money you
wanted to give them personally you'd be
like hmm you know I'll give you five
grand for this project I think it's a
good idea you know what I mean we could
all invest I mean if he had like a
winner it'd be great and then you create
your new economy your parallel economy
in Shark Tank you sometimes have them
competing with each other like no no
don't sign with him I'll do a better
deal I'll do five percent and I'll do
two and a half percent for the same
amount I want in this company that'd be
entertaining people love watching that
yeah it'd be really cool and they like
watching the entrepreneurs yeah you
learn a lot yeah we have a sponsor we
have a sponsor on the show and ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much for
for subscribing to the channel we have a
sponsor on the show moink which is like
a company yeah we have link as well
right and and they started on Shark Tank
oh yeah yeah it's like I I'm a farmer
and I just want to be able to deliver
good meat that's not made in China
poisoned and they're like hey here's the
money and I had I ate my first this is
not an ad right not paid to say this not
here on this show and it's like it's
that's good it's good this is good this
is delicious yeah we we for the audio
side of things we've we've done ads for
them and they send you the big sample
box yeah and it gets annihilated
instantly because like it's real farm
meat it's very good farm meat yes but
that but you're right to not to start
getting into an ad for a company that's
not paying us currently correct but it
is a good company uh they started on
Shark Tank they started on Shark Tank so
there's probably a bunch of success we
could have doing some kind of show like
this where it's like the Consortium of
you know cultural Endeavors or whatever
we should get Kevin O'Leary to come in
and guest host guest dude totally one
day yeah that'd be fun and you realize
how many you are you realize how like
the way that this would work is this
this product would be almost
instantaneously successful because you
put all of our audiences together
focusing on this product
or this prop but let's say moink came to
us let's say a meat Box Company came to
us and we said no that's that's based
real American Meat well we think we've
got local farms all over the place that
sell meat and they come to us and it's
like oh that'd be awesome and then with
the collective audience if you got other
influencers to do this the collective
audience would alone like almost nearly
guarantee the success of this product
yep that's the point of Shark Tank
that's correct they invest in it they
promote it and they make money off of it
let's do the same thing for cultural
Endeavors that's that are anti-woke yes
that believe in America I'm saying it
doesn't have to be conservative it just
has to be not that you know what I mean
can I pitch you one yeah sure okay so my
okay it's just something I've always had
rattling around in my head my my wife
her family has a farm in Delaware it's
Family Farm And they have cows and they
feed their cows beer what do I mean by
that they spent Mash
when you make a beer you have spent mash
and I'm like that is the coolest thing
ever beer cows beer steaks like steaks
that are fed with Jack Daniels spent
Mash or like steaks that have the only
cows that have oh there's entire Market
about this in Japan right with cows that
get massaged and are the wagyu beef oh
they like you're buying a type of beef
that was raised a certain way and these
cows that come from this Farm only eat
beer man that's the most American thing
I've ever heard they're delicious
they're delicious they have a freezer
full of all these steaks and they're
really good and like that would be so
awesome if I could pair my steak I like
wood for Reserve if I could pair my
steak with a cow that's only eaten
Woodford Reserve Mash build and I get to
have my wood for Reserve steak by cow
that's only eaten that the cows love it
it's very nourishing it's full of
nourishment it's full of goodness I'm
gonna cry stop I'm like that would be an
amazing company it's before fermentation
so it's just like grain mesh yeah so you
have to have all this wheat they ate the
wheat anyway right after all those wheat
all this corn and you mash it all
together depending on what you're making
Beer Bourbon barley you put it all
together and it has different types of
mash build means different types of
Bourbons or beers and that's where you
get the taste and so these cows they're
right down the street from Dogfish Head
very famous Brewery and Dogfish has just
dumped in all this spent grain so one
you're actually reusing the grain for
something that's good you're feeding the
animals and you're not having like kill
more plants to feed these animals you're
actually taking the the ant the spent
grain and then you're you're repurposing
this and then you have Dogfish cows so
you have these cows that have only eaten
beer their entire lives it's beautiful
is it noticeable in the flavor I is it's
all it's all AI man like if it's
noticeable if you noticed it yeah yeah
it's not a lie if you believe it right
like George Costanza so it's like it's
noticeable if you see it so I don't mean
to uh you know hijack the comments I can
tell you one I want I'm like I would
love to invest in that I need plugs that
automatically unplug themselves like it
on a timer so like when I fall asleep at
midnight all my plugs though they're
still in the wall wall something
switches and they're no longer plugged
in just in case of solar flare well I
mean there's I don't know about plugging
them in but you can get an Alexa that
does that Alexa stock side will turn off
your your uh plugs actually I'm like
safer solar flare that's what I mean
physically remove them and what a robot
is what you want yeah or even a plastic
C-3PO let's read some more we got Doc
Holliday says redwood trees are only 300
to 350 feet tall only only that's all
really that's very very big that's
that's insanely tall do you know how
tall I am that's not well we our new
building's 40 feet tall the new studio
I'm imagining looking at it and then
imagining that like times seven the
Redwoods are only only 300 feet tall 379
is the tallest on record Hyperion this
is what it's called and they live about
500 to 700 years up to 2 000 years old
got him
wow
all right Raymond just environmental is
Benny Tim are your TVs up yet if not
come on man are you talking about at the
the new building
so uh we need permits and stuff it's
crazy how long it takes we just bought
the building and it's only been a few
months so we're setting up like a
private club it's a coffee shop but
we've got to do design construction so
that's like six months out who knows how
long that'll take forever yeah it's
crazy and then we're we're gonna do the
second floor is going to be like
gaming and you know like board game
skate shop kind of hang out plays with
movies Ian's Crystal Cove is the
mezzanine I guess that we're putting on
the mezzanine where it's going to be a
cool little hangout Nook to watch a
movie and have your coffee then third
floor is going to be like the elite VIP
Club like Social Club not very big there
will be drinks and stuff free drinks
free food a little bit more expensive
but we're gonna bring that you know
cultural building stuff out here to West
Virginia
so I'm excited for that all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com because that
members only live portion of the show is
going up in about 10 minutes and you
don't want to miss it so uh become a
member you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Benny do you want to shout
anything out
uh so we have now thanks to the timcast
audience uh past 770 000 subscribers on
our YouTube and I just want to say thank
y'all y'all are so based I love you big
heart love you we want to get to a
million Subs this year and I think we're
going to get there
um and stay based right on
I am Phil Labonte uh I am Phil that
remains on Twitter and uh Phil that
remains official on Instagram give me a
follow I'm Ian Crossland hit me up
anywhere on the internet Benny always a
pleasure man that was really great and
how fun was this shout out to your wife
nurse Kate nurse Kate nurse Kate keeping
it real Graham if you're into fitness if
you want to live a healthier lifestyle
follow nurse Kate on Instagram thank you
sir
yeah thanks Benny um I watch you on
YouTube all the time I appreciate it let
me let me get that yeah yeah there you
go uh watch all the time appreciate it
glad you went to East Palestine
good to see you here all right everybody
make sure you go to timcast.com we're
going to have that live uncensored show
up in about 10 minutes and we will see
you all there